[Music]  dr. mikail  our shop ski is a family medicine  physician do you have this massive  following on youtube you trying to do  something different to what ordinary  doctors are trying to do but who's gone  out that he saved a man's life on a  flight to Israel dr. Mike is coming  after Micah's calculus so he's  compassionate he's knowledgeable we want  to get your take on this dr. Mike is  here to show us how all right now they  just begin to come on why do I sweat so  much more in the normal people it's  right here what collagen what about  collagen can i overdose some claritin  should I be concerned that I pee all the  time  what are your thoughts in general about  the the vaping situation I hope she's  not gonna shock the patient oh my god  please tell me she's not gonna know  their right lung let's get it out of  here this is not the way you perform  surgery right an early day time to be a  doctor who feeds this to babies  definitely not doing this  [Music]